Vsauce Kevin here up hang on a second
[Music]
ah
[Music]
ah man now I have to pee wait why do we
pee and poop in clean water I did
disinfect the bowl and refill it because
the toilet could contain harmful
bacteria but the water is fine so how
did artificial rivers falling in and out
of a tiny artificial pond become the
most common way to remove waste and how
does an English poets attempt to sweeten
air and an Austrian Holocaust survivors
dirt toilet factor into what a british
medical journal poll revealed to be the
most important health problem of the
last 150 years
poop humans can either poop in the
ground and cover it with dirt or poop in
water and walk away
we've pooped in water by building
toilets over canals like the Romans in
4th century BC building toilets on
bridges like the London Bridge privies
in 1382 or using a hanging toilet which
is basically a chair at the end of a
dock with a hole in it water is the
quickest easiest way to get poop out of
sight and more importantly to our
ancestors out of smell for much of
history bad smells weren't just
unpleasant they were thought to carry
illness before the discovery of germs in
1880 the miasma theory was dominant it
held that sickness like cholera which is
acquired by drinking water contaminated
with feces was actually caused by
breathing smelly poison air the word
malaria a disease commonly transmitted
by mosquitoes comes from the Italian
mala Aria meaning bad air the bad air
from dead bodies was thought to spread
the plague the Black Death killed almost
1/3 of Europe in the 14th century
13:48 ordinances for sanitation at a
time of mortality in pistoia set strict
rules on sealing dead bodies in coffins
and establishing the specific depth of
their burial during England's Great
Plague in 1665 the Mayor of London
attempted to prevent plague-ridden
stench from infecting the living by
mandating that bodies must be buried 6
feet deep
over 200 years later in the wake of
pioneering German research from Louie
Pasteur and Robert Koch French biologist
Alexandre Yersin
finally found the plagues cause
bacterium carried by fleas living on
rodents smells don't carry sickness but
they can signal a biological warning to
help us avoid something dangerous
pathogens and human feces cause
illnesses ranging from typhoid fever to
hookworm and we believe that dislike of
odors from bodily fluids is an
evolutionary response to avoid disease
order molecules bind to specialized
receptors in the back of the nose
located on millions of olfactory neurons
which goes straight to the brain where
they're deciphered fresh food is
typically safe and typically smells good
rotten food is often dangerous and often
smells bad and preventing stench and
sickness was the motivation for the John
the Sir John Sir John Harington an
English poet and prominent member of
Queen Elizabeth the first royal court
wrote about his flush toilet invention
in 1596 but his desire to sweeten the
air would go unfulfilled for centuries
one reason his technology was ignored
was that the rich simply had no need for
a complicated toilet they had servants
the groom of the stool a job which later
gave way to the lady of the bedchamber
not only disposed of waste by emptying
the chamber pot but also literally wiped
their royal butts but you don't have to
be royalty to not want to deal with
waste individuals generally leave their
waste in the nearest water source or a
hole in the ground until it becomes
someone else's problem which it usually
does the tragedy of the Commons is an
economic theory that describes how
everyone acting in their own
self-interest can destroy a resource
used by an entire community
Victorian economist William Foster Lloyd
coined the term in 1833 to illustrate
the problem with cows grazing on shared
land
if each individual grazed their cows
without limit they'd eventually bring
more and more cows until the land became
so over grazed that no one could use it
now imagine a city tripling in
population from 1 to 3 million people in
just half a century with everyone
dumping industrial and human waste into
one River combine that with an unusually
hot summer and you get stink in London
1858 it was the great stink outbreaks of
Cholera were blamed on the smell from
the banks of the River Thames Chancellor
of the Exchequer Benjamin Disraeli
described the river as a stingy and pool
reeking with ineffable and intolerable
horrors an English physicist Michael
Faraday said near the bridges the
feculent rolled up in clouds so dense
that they were visible at the surface
social scientist George Godwin
documented piles of untreated waste on
the banks as being up to 6 feet deep an
average male height at the time was
about 5'4
the government accepted a proposal from
civil engineer Joseph thousand jet to
build an elaborate sewer system that
hairy waist to six different outlets
each emptying into the ocean it took 20
years to complete but 100 years later
the Thames was declared dead after
wartime bombing destroyed parts of basil
Jets sewer the Manchester Guardian
described the Thames as a badly managed
open sewer and in 1957 the Natural
History Museum declared it biologically
dead despite resistance to cleanup
including a member of the House of Lords
stating in 1959 that breaking up sewage
gave rivers something to do waste
treatment improved advances involved
screening and cleaning the wastes before
releasing the filtered water back into
waterways and today the Thames once
again supports wildlife it took nearly
300 years improvements in civil
engineering and a public disaster for
Sir John Harington 's flushable toilet
to be widely adopted and now the water
in the toilet is the same water that
comes from the tap
which in many areas is perfectly
drinkable the end but wait billions of
people lack access to flush toilets and
whether the ground is too frozen the
land is too dry or a community is too
poverty-stricken complex water sewage
systems don't exist in much of the world
1.8 billion suffer every year from
ingesting water contaminated with waste
flowing toilets are used in the slums of
Kenya and Haiti their plastic bags used
as toilets and then flung as far as the
user can throw them hitting people
piling on roofs and bursting open when
they hit the ground clogging drainage
systems and contaminating water in India
where more people have cell phones than
access to a toilet newly installed
toilets are often ignored because of
taboos regarding cleaning them out the
government and World Bank developed a no
toilet no bride campaign to influence
families to have a proper toilet before
getting married
the future of poop requires a paradigm
shift described by American physicist
Thomas Kuhn as a fundamental change in
the basic concepts of a scientific
discipline while spider webs of water
pipes pushing waste for centralized
processing was rated the greatest
medical advance in 150 years
Friedensreich Hundertwasser advocated
for a different approach his solution
was pooping kinda like cats litter boxes
play on a cat's natural instinct to
defecate in soft sandy soil by making a
cat toilet out of moisture and odour
absorbing material but instead of
throwing the waste away like owners do
with cats Austrian painter and architect
Hundertwasser wanted human poop to
return to its natural purpose the human
toilet is a composting toilet that works
by having a layer of houmous at the
bottom of a bucket and then scooping
some fresh hummus on top of the poop
after each use with no bad smell Sir
John Harington would approve a double
bottom allows for airflow and a drip
trough and eventually the contents turn
into fertilizer called humanure
the word human actually derives from the
Latin word houmous meaning earth and
ground and humanness meaning man and the
human toilet
according to Hundertwasser represented a
direct cycle of life between people and
planet his concern was that flush
toilets divorce humanity from a basic
circle of life with waste turning into
fertilizer for plant life the death of
food becomes the birth of vegetation
saying what comes out of us is not waste
but the building block of the world and
while poop might not exactly be Lego it
was worth some money
human excrement entering sewer systems
was actually opposed in mid 19th century
France by night soil collectors named
because they did their dirty work at
night they didn't want to lose their job
gathering and selling poop to be made
into fertilizer and pee to be made into
the saltpeter used for gunpowder
companies around the world are starting
to see the dollar signs in duty
utilizing waste from urban sewage
treatment facilities is gaining steam as
technology advances for turning bio
solids into fuel and energy and toiletry
inventions are underway including a
solar toilet from the California
Institute of Technology that generates
hydrogen and electricity and the
Cranfield nano membrane toilet which
separates and cleans water from waste
the leftover is covered in wax to seal
pathogens
ALPA dry out to be later used for energy
waxy poop balls might not be the direct
cycle hundred Vossler desired but
toiletry inventions represent the unique
marriage between humanity and the planet
the engineering of Sir John Harington
with the ecological philosophy of
Hundertwasser a direct theme of hundred
fosters work was his rejection of
straight lines preferring spirals and
squiggles
he believed straight lines were a human
construct that
separated us from nature and a straight
line was the design flaw in Harrington's
toyline a straight pipe allowed gas to
rise up directly into the water closet
from below Alexander [ __ ] invented
the S strap in 1775 which allowed
standing water to block the foul air a
squiggly line perfected Harrington's
toilet but hundred foster cared about
people and improving the most basic
parts of their lives saying I want to
make people happy not depressed I don't
want to burden them with more problems
they already have enough he knew
problems having survived the Holocaust
when at least 69 of his family didn't
and thought that returning to a state of
beauty in her interactions with nature
would ensure our survival hundred busser
believed in the earth cycle so strongly
he used himself as fertilizer when he
died of congestive heart failure in 2000
he was buried without a coffin under a
tulip tree only two feet deep no one
visits his grave they visit his tree
Friedensreich Hundertwasser a circle is
complete and through this perspective of
death and rebirth we reinvent our waist
and our bodies sewage becomes energy and
we become a forest of the Living Dead
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
special thanks to Neil Brahma Hall for
his stunning nature footage and in extra
special thanks to everyone at the
hundred Vassar Foundation